[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
y'all there man what's up i was just
scrolling
taking a dive in on my
fan dual
app looking for some bets tonight
i don't know i'm kind of torn tonight
i'll be honest i'm going to be honest i
am kind of torn
i'm nervous i want this one to be over
i want to enjoy my father's day i'll
tell you that much on sunday
um
but
who knows who knows what's going to
happen in boston
that's why you guys are here that's why
i need you guys that's why i need you
guys to fill up that chat because we
have to discuss this we have to discuss
where is the angle
today
where is the ling today where is the
money to be made today usually i'll just
go off and i'll tell y'all
bet the warriors y'all know me i'm i
like to bet and ride with my whole team
but tonight
today
june 16th i'm
i'm nervous i'm i'm nervous i'm nervous
so we we go see i'm let me let me uh
let me see if anybody's in the chat i
see deep geek is in the chat already
what up deep geek what up man ryan is in
the chat what up ryan um
let me hear let me let me pee
ryan says al horford legacy game
why are we talking about al horford
why are we talking about al horford i
mean
guy had a good game one
bounced back
he bounced back in a couple of games but
why are we
a legacy game for al horford man you
know what let's get this show started
i'm ready to get this show started
let's go be money let's get this thing
started uh
it's three one
three
[Music]
no actually three two not three one
three two
game six in boston today
warriors boston
i don't know which way to go i don't
know which way to lean so when i don't
know which way to go and i don't know
which way to lean usually you guys
already know i'm always rocking with my
warriors so this might mean something
you guys might be able to take something
from this take an angle from it
i don't know i don't know which way to
go but i know when i don't know which
way to go i know who to tap in with and
that is with my boy s dot i call him s
dot you all call him sam richman let me
bring him in sam
what's happening brother how you feeling
i feel great man i also love that you're
playing this like i don't know what to
you're going to bet the warriors let's
just we know what you're going to do but
i love that you're you're trying to
tease the audience yeah which way you're
leading i'm just being honest i'm being
honest today i really
do not know which way to go i i sam my
heart says the warriors my mind says the
warriors
but
game six
in boston
i feel like the nba won seven
i know what that means for the nba if
they get seven
so that's how i'm thinking sam i'm i'm
i'm trying to think smart here
i love that well can i can i start
giving my picks can i just can i follow
right into it because that's a nice
place
all right start off number one
all right first pick
i'm with you greg
celtics minus three and a half hopefully
people can see it i've got very bad
internet hopefully that is going through
uh that's how we start going
seriously like that's how you feel it
we're gonna end on a good note i i
promise you that it might take a while
like i said this last week but this week
i really mean it we're gonna end on a
really good note for you you gotta talk
about yeah i like it's minus three and a
half is your luck
yeah i like the celtics and i i think
there's
i like how you talk about angles here's
my angle tonight
the warriors have been in this position
the past few series when they've had a
chance to close out a series on the road
with another game at home waiting for
them on the back burner and every time
they've had that they have lost this
game including losing by
50 to memphis they lost to denver
they didn't close out the mavs they like
to close out series at home um
and i think they know that i think they
feel comfortable about having a game
seven at chase center i also really like
that the celtics haven't lost three
games in a row since like december and i
know you could have said that give me a
chance
i'm so sorry um bro do not give me that
don't get cause because at first it was
the celtics don't lose back-to-backs
that happened now it's like they don't
lose back-to-back come on man
what else celtics not gonna lose
championships like
the celtics fans you they are coming up
with every statistic every formula to
try to come up with the way for the
celtics to win i'm
sam
don't give me that
you're not wrong you're not wrong and i
just want to say like every single
celtics fan and better said the same
thing for game five and look we can we
can go in a different direction here
look i've always said i think the
celtics are the better team i'm i'm
nearing pulling back from that take and
i could go on a long rant about how
disappointed i've been with him these
last few games but maybe i'll save that
for later but i'm with you they they
have been a very resilient team and i i
do think the warriors again like they
when they have that close-out game back
at home they've kind of let go a little
bit so we're going celtics minus three
and a half for the first pick
that two sam bet two second pick
under 210
which
if you'll remember okay
sam's rocking with the under talk to me
celtics been struggling
to hit the 100 mark
the last couple of games that's the
thing
also looks like my internet is picking
up which is great that's great vibes uh
hopefully now you can see the signs but
yeah i like under 210 today i think i
this is one of the few
rare things i got correct on last time
show um that i thought once this series
got longer um you would start to see the
under start to catch more um and we're
seeing that i mean if we're at the point
with tired legs where steph curry is
going oh for nine and nina's game home
like we are at the point of todd lakes
this is the point game six in game seven
in these series where it's all out
defense every single possession of the
game um and i think we see that tonight
and yeah the celtics offense is is
looking a little murky right now the
warriors on the road obviously better at
home so i like the under i think this is
just one of these super physical super
aggressive games that kind of get from
the mud a bit and i think the under cash
is tonight i'm in the comments and i
think that this one plays well with what
you're talking about my man bagel and
lock says reps are coming to play
tonight you think
the reps are going to have an angle in
this one going over
under do you think the refs are going to
play a a part in this one sam
well first i have to shout out d geek
saying sam's internet is the funniest
gag ever so i love that someone thinks
this is like a bit and not like i just
have awful internet um so
that makes me happy but yeah no i mean
well you know no scott foster tonight
everyone was looking for the extender to
run this game no scott foster so i don't
know i i just think it's going to be a
very physical game i i
big boston crowd i you know that crowd
is really rowdy so i like celtics i like
the under tonight but hey we're now
we're going man
max rescue says sam spinning his
internet budget on celtics minus three
and a half
that's probably why your internet is
what it is sam because you're putting
your internet bill money on these bets
that uh you know that i don't really
necessarily agree with but that is okay
let's move on to bet number three sam
talk to him you gave us two we need the
third one
um yes greg let's talk after the show
though because i need you to help me
pull some strings to get better internet
i don't have the juice like that so i
need your help but next bet
next bet this is going to be a little
controversial and i actually wrote it
incorrectly myself the first time and i
said i could get a new piece of paper
and rewrite it and i said nope i'm going
to be lazy i'm just going to cross it
out and rewrite it we are going draymond
over 0.53 tonight uh which is hey sam i
don't know if you saw me wiping my eyes
but bring that up one more time brother
bring that up one more time because i
got to see that clearly
what what i dropped piece of paper so i
got to grab it again it's okay
oh so he's gonna hit a three
he's gonna hit three tonight i'm betting
on you guys i like that i i like that
dre's do he's due
he he's he's doing good i'll tell you
what draymond did to me sam i parlayed
draymond this was a game four when the
warriors won they were plus money i
parlay the warriors money line plus
money in draymond to get eight points my
man only had two
so i'm hoping i'm praying and sending
you good vibes you put this uh bet in
andre
that he can cash for you brother
he let me down let me down
here
here's the thing it's plus 200 and he i
think he's hit like two threes this
entire post season i think he's like two
for like 25 30. it's been awful no doubt
about that but
he's still getting the shots up i think
he took two last game a lot of games
with three a lot of games with four he's
getting them up and let's just
yeah maybe he's like a percent sure
right now but like for his career for
the season he's about 25 30
you give me two chances at 25 30 for one
of them to go in at plus 200 like
honestly pretty good like i feel like
the kind of number is swung in in a way
that it's now bettable where people are
so down andre so at plus 200 pretty
intriguing so i i'm going hey sam one
thing one thing we know he's gonna put
up a shot or two he's going to put up a
shot or two it's just the particles in
the air it's just up to the vibes in the
air it's just up to the you know
whatever it is in the atmosphere
or that moment it needs to all align all
click and go in
for you to cash that draymond greens
over three point bet uh that's enough
about this one let's go bet four sam
give it to the people
i just i said this yesterday i just love
the comment section and just people are
like someone kevlos said i've been
betting the dream on three all series
and nothing just some just some good
comments in the chats but tonight
tonight it gets better um all right
fourth bet
you're not gonna like this one
but
jordan poole wow under 11.5 points and
i'm going to hold on
blake preston is in the chat he says
what about jordan pull over 11 and a
half points
sam
i don't know
i might be i might be siding with my man
blake sam
so so let me let me explain so
here's the thing
he he's been shooting the ball really
well but he's been getting his minutes
cut recently um because i think he's
kind of like defensive matchups i think
he played like 17 minutes in the last
game because kerr likes peyton let me
look it up he's liking the porter
matchups yeah yeah look it up right now
it's been around 17 20 minutes in the
series
and wow sam you're right he played 14
minutes he played 14 minutes yeah in the
last game
yeah if you're getting 14 15 minutes in
a game asking someone as good of an
offensive scorer as he is to get
12 points is a lot and i feel like again
he's also
you know the he's
he's a guy who i like more at home in a
home game just like feeds off the crowd
all of those buzzer beaters at the end
of quarters have been at home he feeds
off that on the road in a close-out game
in the finals to me this feels like a
steph clay draymond the og type game it
feels like you're gonna get less from
pool so yeah if he's playing 15 minutes
out you know under 11 half i think is a
good bet hey d geek is in the comments
saying the pool party is over i don't
think the pool party is over
jordan poole minutes are very important
that's usually when steph goes to the
bench or clay goes to the bench they put
in jordan pool to run the offense
so those minutes are very very important
and if the warriors want to win i feel
like i need to see some point scored by
uh jordan paul today sam you gave us i
think four or five bets already
let's get to the next one
uh but before hold on before let me talk
let me see what the chat is talking
about let me see what the chat is
talking about uh b connor 32 says i'm
taking warriors here bro it is close out
time i agree with you be kind of 32 sam
does it i don't know why but i'm working
on them i am slowly but surely working
sam you have two futures bro you might
as well like what
are you making more money with the
warrior uh with the celtics
yes that's why i've been rooting for
this i hear i'll find i'll give you my
i'll give you my six bet fifth to get
you back on my good side
let's go that show
yeah yeah so i think that pays out about
plus 145. look i i want the celtics win
like i said i win more money if they do
but you'll remember greg from i think i
said it's last two shows i think if it
gets to seven games the warriors are at
a huge advantage at home i think we're
getting a seventh game um and i just i
like i said i i've always said i think
the celtics are the better team and i've
been able to say like oh if they just
don't have stupid turnovers or oh if
they um if they don't like totally
abandon their offense at the end of late
games but i hate to say it i'm kind of
reaching the point where it's just like
that's just who they are you know they
have a ton of sloppy turnovers it is
you can't just say like if they don't it
just that's what they do so i i trust
the warriors in game seven i do think
the celtics get it done tonight at home
but i think warriors and seven and about
plus 150 um
is a good bet and i think that's that is
how the series ends i think the warriors
do get it done hey sam you know what i'm
really not gonna be
mad about i kinda i'm gonna feel a
little salty because i do want this to
be over as soon as possible but if it do
go seven
i did first show that we had uh for
these finals i said warriors in seven so
that will make me you know make me look
make me look like you make me look like
a sharp a little bit uh
but
i want to transition sam because maybe i
might like the shirt a little bit
you got one more
whoa yeah one more
that's on me hey brother that's on me i
want the people to get this clay bed in
because you know game six clay is coming
up but uh sam talk to the people talk to
me what else do you have for us
so this conflicts with my last bet but i
do think this is a good value bet and i
think if the celtics win the series i
really like this bet it is jaylen brown
mvp at plus 1800.
i look i think
jason tatum has like not been very good
in the series he's shooting like 25
on two pointers so i think it's pretty
up in the air if the celtics win the
series who wins it and the fact that
tatum is being priced around plus 400
jaylen is around plus 1800 i i think he
could have a big game time he could get
back in the mix so well here here's my
take here's my largest take no one else
is bettable right now because steph the
number is just crazy but he is going to
win
he's going to win and it's like i know
people are talking about andrew wiggins
being a contender for mvp and it's like
no if the warriors win the series steph
is winning it but i just i it's minus
400 so if i'm looking for a little value
down the board just a little sprinkle on
jalen but i know you've got a really
good clay bet so
brett show let's show the tweet i'm i'm
done with sam jalen brown's not winning
mvp we're rocking with steph mvp even if
the warriors lose i'm rocking with steph
mvp but look trey young is in the mix my
man trey young got a tweet
i was on twitter sam earlier and i saw
this one says
you you guys can read it clay might be
going for 50 tonight he's just getting
warm w i saw him earlier warming up uh
on instagram from 95.7 they were showing
clay getting ready
nice and loose i'm feeling good about it
and i'm feeling so good about this sam i
got a question for you and i got a
question for the audience
clay total points was sitting at 19 and
a half
sitting at
but i was dibbling and dabbling a little
bit more sam because you know that's
what i like to do and i like to find
plus money i like to find plus money and
i saw clay
25 plus points sitting at plus 250 so my
question is to you my question is to the
audience
which one of these is the better bet
today
we all know what klay thompson does
during game six matchups he's proof time
after time year after year he even
proved
this in this year's playoffs what he
does in game six situations
i'm putting my money on clay the
question is are you and which one of
these should we bet on sam i'm starting
off with you first
should we just take the regular point
total 19 and a half sitting at minus 120
or should we get a little greedy not too
greedy just a little greedy we know clay
like to hit three so this is two threes
more
and take the 25
plus points sitting at plus 250.
well first i got i'm just i'm you could
probably see me laughing the comments
when you brought up the trey young tweet
everyone's just flaming trey young
someone called him fraud young someone
called him el rey lung like p d geek
when i people are just absolutely
flaming trey young which is great nba
finals uh hawks eliminated two months
ago and everyone's uh just going after
trey young love that um
i greg i'll be honest i use this bomb i
am a you know i'm a loser so i would
probably just play it safe and take the
over 19 and a half try and give my best
chance at a win and not go too crazy um
with the plus 250 but that's because i'm
lame and i'm boring so i'm more curious
the audience take
my man sam is trying to play it
conservative
sam honestly i don't dislike it i really
want to sprinkle both i don't see why
shouldn't we sprinkle both if clay lands
on the middle number hey we still gotta
win if clay lands on the higher number
hey we got two wins i don't know i want
to see what you guys are talking about
i'm in the chat gabriel donnis21 says
game six clay baby and steph coming off
a bad game they're locking it in tonight
i love that type of energy sam i don't
know if you like that energy but uh i do
j
lo i been j lo ivan 12 says
plus 2 30
for clay to score 25 easy money for game
6 clay i love the energy in these
comments sam you said that there was
energy you said the comments are all
over the place you said that they're
jumping but i like it i also got
moneyline killer in the comments saying
i love clay but not today in my greg
voice wow moneyline killer that was a
curveball i thought you were rocking
with clay but still those are all good
vibes those are all good vibes
you guys let me know which way you guys
are writing um
but sam i got some more tweets for you
brother i got some more tweets for you
let's pull up tweet number one i know
sam you're a big shock quality guy big
shop quality guy
i want you to look at this
because this is based off of what you
like to project your bets on you like to
talk about sam you like to talk about
shot quality but in the last game you
guys can read there it is
the warriors shot quality wasn't the
best
but they still won by 10 points but sam
you still have the celtics covering
today
i'm lost yeah
i'm i'm lost like
you have to talk bro don't be quiet now
you you have to talk you have to speak
up
you like shot quality i brought up some
statistics about shot quality and and
now what
my internet's breaking up greg i missed
no i'm just kidding i heard everything
yeah no like i said the last game was
was really disappointing as someone who
believed in the celtics and thought they
were the better team the warriors punked
him they played a lot better they should
have won by more points like no denying
that i know there's
you know a lot of talk you know about
the refs with these games as there
always was but that wasn't a refs game
the warriors were just better team
i just i believe the celtics will bounce
back at home but uh like i said i still
like the warriors to win the series i'm
still with you like
i've i've changed yeah i like how you're
just not referring to shock quality
while answering the question but that is
okay because we know you're a shock
quality guy but that that sam that's
that's perfectly fine let's move on to
the next talking point tweet number two
uh
you kind of mentioned this you i mean
you you kind of did you you know you
brought the celtics don't lose three
games in a row thing
you guys see the statistic right there
celtics 3-0 elimination games they talk
about my warrior in road closeout games
is there gonna be a game seven i think
sam that's why i came into the show and
everybody knows i am one of the most
confident
people when it comes to betting on my on
my bay area teams golden state warriors
49ers san francisco giants i will come
and i will defend them to the throne but
today
i just i i uh i don't know because i
think that it's going to seven sam i'm
sure you think that is gonna go seven
right
i'm just getting flamed in the comments
right now uh this is the best people are
just laughing about how you know stupid
i am and uh how i was how you left me
speechless
um and people are roasting the internet
as well um someone said i don't know
which one's worse uh sam's internet or
his picks great take love that um but i
i to me the bigger stat here is the
warriors being 0-3 in road closeout
games i think that's the one i have
fixated on more than others they just
seem to know have this just supreme
confidence that they can get the job
done at home and they've been right at
every point in every series that that is
correct and they kind of drop the ball
in these road closeout games i think
that happens here uh again but i like i
said i i think the warriors still win
sam's at this point but you know what
brother i'm confused i'm so confused
because we just did a segment where you
had a chance
to give six bets right you gave us six
bets
but then i was on your twitter earlier
right and i saw you tweet something
let's pull up tweet number three so i
can show the people what i'm talking
about my man sam was talking about
that's a girl on twitter great tweet
bro you were talking about draymond
green on twitter but then you came in
here and you said jaylen brown will win
mvp
sam are you okay like
is is draymond i mean
i get he's a big eye like he's plus
what's that 25 000 he's big odds but
it's like
are you just like or are you just
tweeting things just to tweet them or is
this like what what's going on sam like
you got to talk to me about this
i want to be very clear here this is not
me advocating to bet on draymond green
to win finals mvp i just thought it was
very funny that his name is even on the
odds board because he's been so awful in
the series and it just got me thinking
like what is the actual scenario that
results in draymond green
winning finals mvp and i've come to the
conclusion that i think he would need
100 points tonight to do it i think if
he scored 80 i don't think it's enough i
think he needs the full 100 wilt
chamberlain game to win finals mvp uh i
i think that's what it is i'm curious
your channel that's that's like that's a
little i think it's that happens
to decide you guys let me know in the
comments
is sam uh
is he contradicting himself by tweeting
this and telling us that it has him
thinking and you know it might be
interesting to take a look at draymond
green but then comes in here and drops
jaylen brown as one of his picks is my
man sam contradicting y'all let me know
in the comments
sam uh
it's been fun it's been fun it's it's
been fun
we're gonna be back here
uh i believe we're gonna be back here
next week if this if they go seven i
don't know maybe not maybe so it's been
fun
sam
they want us to talk about this last
tweet they want us to talk about this
last tweet i was trying to pass it i was
not trying to talk about it because
we're talking about the celtics
and do they have anybody on their team
playing like a star do you think that
they have anybody on their team playing
like a star
no i mean i like i love jason tatum but
it's like i don't he's shooting 25 from
two point range and it's like that's not
good enough you're being doing that i've
been super disappointed like it's just
it's just been bad man
i i thought more of this team and i
think like i said i think they can
bounce back tonight and win it i don't
think they're totally bad in the series
i think they have a chance but like man
it's it's hard not to lose confidence in
this team right now it's
sad
sad for me it is hard not to lose
confidence but peep this i'm back into
the chat
cada bisman he says i'm a laker fan so i
would never root for the celtics but
boston is forcing a game seven tonight
wow that is big uh lakers fans saying
that the boston celtics are winning
today uh
k k gallagher to al horford over one and
a half threes it's plus money why are we
talking about al horford why like
what
jason tatum you hate al horford man you
hate it mark is smart
why are we talk sam why are we talking
about al horford
why i got one more one worked in the
chat greg wearing boston green on his
shirt
hey
i'm a company man bro these are the new
br betting shirts
i'm the first to rock it this is one of
one right now but this can be in you
guys's hands
real real soon uh make sure you guys
check it out make sure you guys go cop
one um
but sam
ryan's in the comments and this is gonna
be the last one ryan's in the comments
says no team that has forced the game
six in the nba's finals has ever gotten
more disrespect
hey
i do this to everybody
i do this to everybody that's facing the
goats i mean let's be honest let's you
guys like to say that you think the the
celtics is the better team they're not
the better team like they're not they're
not the better team in my opinion
the warriors have superstars they have
multiple superstars and they have
multiple first battle hall of famers i'm
just going to stop it right there
because we're going to keep on talking
all day if we were
we're going to continue to talk about
this sam we're just going to keep on
going all day
all day and all day but my name is greg
ivory that's sam richmond and we
are out of here peace
[Music]
you